elon musk made 142 billion
last year mostly due to an unprecedented
run in tesla stock
this allowed him to become the richest
person in the world and many tesla
investors to make life-changing amounts
of money
in the stock market though there's a
popular saying that the market takes the
stairs up
and the elevator down so here's why elon
musk is in risk of taking the elevator
down
very soon starting off
we all know that tesla's evaluation is
out there
personally i'm super optimistic about
tesla and the long-term dominance in
terms of electric vehicles
autonomous vehicles and even solar
energy but
take a look at this tesla is literally
worth as much as the rest of the
automotive industry combined
while only pulling in 2.1 of the revenue
now many will argue that tesla is a tech
company and the self-driving technology
is what really justifies its valuation
i'm sure this will be true 10 or 15
years down the line
but i'm skeptical about this argument
today here's the thing
people who invested into amazon during
1998 and 1999 thinking that the internet
and e-commerce with the future
were 100 right but they were a bit too
early
and a bit too excited if they bought a
dot-com highs of about
113 dollars per share in 1999 they would
be up massively today
as amazon trades at well over three
thousand dollars at the same time though
it would have taken them a full ten
years just to break even
more importantly at one point in 2001
they would have been down 95
on their investment as amazon would dip
to just six dollars a share
now i'm not saying that tesla will also
drop 90 or 95
from all-time highs just like amazon
though that is possible
rather what i think is more likely is a
40 or 50
pullback from all-time highs and here's
why
first of all we're not going to be
talking about any financial metrics like
p e ratio
forward p ratio rsi macd or anything
like that
all of those indicators are extremely
overextended especially on the weekly
chart
moreover technical analysis isn't a very
concrete piece of evidence for an
upcoming crash
anyways if you were basing your
decisions on metrics like the pe ratio
you probably would have been bearish on
tesla for nearly a year at this point
and you likely missed out on a lot of
gains so instead we'll focus on the
rudimentary basics of stock price
movement
which are just buyers and sellers if
there are more buyers than sellers
the stock goes up and if there are more
sellers and buyers the stock goes down
that's it all of those fancy indicators
and metrics are simply methods to
predict if there are going to be more
buyers or more sellers
so in order to understand why there
might be an influx of sellers coming up
let's take a look at why there was an
influx of buyers in the first place
starting with short sellers heading into
tesla was the most shortest stock in the
us short sellers are individuals who
profit when the stock goes down
however if this stock goes up they end
up feeling the upward momentum when they
exit their positions
this phenomenon is called a short
squeeze and is the same as what we saw
with gamestop stock recently
one key difference between the two
scenarios though is that tesla stocks
start to rally because the fundamentals
of the company were improving
while gamestop rallied just because it
was shorted way too much and wall street
bets decided to punish the shorts
regardless of what caused the short
squeeze one of the main reasons tesla
stock skyrocketed like gamestop
was because of short sellers there are
still notable people trying to short
tesla stock like michael berry
but the vast majority have stopped
trying to short tesla simply because
they have lost so much money
in fact short sellers lost 40 billion in
2020.
as a result the short interest in tesla
stands at just 5.46 percent
today thus we won't be seeing another
short squeeze with tesla
anytime soon moving on another major
factor driving tesla's historic run
was single time events tesla finally
posted their first profitable year in
2020.
this was especially impactful has led
massive amounts of short sellers to exit
their positions in july of 2020
and it allowed tesla to enter the s p
500 however
neither of these events can ever happen
again or
i guess they technically can but that
would involve tesla becoming
unprofitable again
and then getting kicked out of the s p
500 which would indicate even bigger
problems
given that tesla is growing and
improving we'll likely never see this
catalyst again
the same thing goes for the stock split
as well tesla stock rallied 66
in anticipation of the stock split first
of all tesla shouldn't have rallied at
all because of that news
considering that doesn't change anything
fundamental about the company
moreover stock splits usually only
happen once every several years
so we don't have this catalyst on our
side either looking forward
many of you guys might argue that the
rollout of full self-driving software
may act as a catalyst and do i agree
that level 5 autonomy will be a major
advantage for tesla
i don't think that will be reflected in
the stock price just think about what
happened after battery
and autonomy day so unfortunately we're
running out of big single time events
that will impact tesla stock
positively next up something else to
consider
is that many people were getting into
tesla stock for the first time in 2020.
many investors both institutional and
retail brought off tesla stock for
several years
as they were literally in risk of going
bankrupt now that tesla's financial
situation has vastly improved though
many investors have poured into tesla
something to note though
is that the majority of people buying
into tesla bought in during spring
and summer of 2020. ever since then the
volume of tesla stock traded every
single day has been on a constant
decline
during spring and summer of 2020 400 to
500 million shares of tesla were being
traded
every single week in the third week of
february 2021 however
this number was just 82.48 million
shares
meaning that volume decreased by roughly
80 to 90 percent
this indicates the majority of people
who wanted to get into tesla
are already in tesla also the majority
of them are likely significantly
in the green run-ups on low volume like
this are extremely dangerous
as we don't know what the majority of
shareholders actually think about the
price
today it's possible that many of them
think it's overvalued
but they're continuing to hold because
it just keeps running up if the stock
price starts to show weakness
or starts to dip it's quite possible
that many of these people will take
profits
thus adding to the selling pressure
anyways another major factor propelling
tesla forward
is of course low interest rates and the
federal reserve printing basically
unlimited money neither of these seem to
be stopping anytime soon
so that's good for the stock market in
general however
something that is likely coming to an
end is stimulus checks
congress and the white house are put out
of a second round of seamless checks for
several months at this point
but now that a new administration is
finally settling in it looks like the
second seamless bill will finally be
passed in the imminent future
this would generally be a good thing
however this bill has been anticipated
for so long that i think most of it has
already been priced
into stocks for instance let's take a
look at the nasdaq 100
around the election the nasdaq 100
hovered at 11 000
today the nasdaq stands at well over 13
thousand dollars
meaning that the nasdaq has white about
20 since the election
keep in mind that indices like the
nasdaq and s p 500 grow 8 to ten percent
every year
on average so the market is clearly
pricing in some sort of good news
before it actually happens and i think
that this is the upcoming stimulus bill
as well as vaccine distribution what
happens though when the stimulus bill is
actually passed
and the average person gets the vaccine
we may very well see another pop in
stocks as the news comes out
but i think this boost will be
short-lived and finally
that brings me on to the final major
reason that tesla stock may be shaky
moving forward
which is a recent purchase of bitcoin
now i'm not against bitcoin by any means
i actually think bitcoin will perform
quite well over the long term
however this is not the case with many
institutional investors
in tesla we do have some institutional
people like kathy wood and chummy
palakka patia who have a positive
outlook on bitcoin
but the majority of wall street has the
same view as gary black
who thinks bitcoin is crude as a result
many of these institutions are slowly
selling their tesla stake or have
already sold their tesla positions
this actually might be the main reason
that we have seen weakness with tesla
stock since the bitcoin purchase
announcement
aside from this the purchase of bitcoin
introduced a major threat for tesla's
bottom line
you'll see tesla only net profits a few
hundred million dollars per quarter
which as a proportion of the revenue is
quite small
meanwhile they recently purchased 1.5
billion worth of bitcoin
when bitcoin was at about 30 000 since
then
bitcoin has value to over 50 000 which
means that tesla profited about 1
billion
from this investment already ironically
that's more than tesla has made
throughout their entire history selling
cars
and this is where things get dangerous
you see
whenever bitcoin goes up tesla can't
claim it as profit on their financial
reports
until they sell their stake however if
bitcoin dips below their purchase price
they must report it as a loss as they
can't guarantee that it will recover
as a result if bitcoin pulls back like
it so often does
tesla could very well end up with quite
a red quarterly report even if their
core business
is doing well at the end of the day
tesla stock is no longer heavily shorted
they don't have very many major
catalysts coming up they're rallying on
low volume
and they just made an investment that
might hurt their bottom line
with all that being said i think sellers
may continue to outweigh buyers
moving forward causing tesla to ride the
elevator down just like it did
last monday i personally think that this
will simply be a great buying
opportunity though
as tesla has an outstanding future long
term do you guys agree that tesla stock
is going to pull back quite
substantially
before it moons once again comment that
down below
also drop a like if you guys thought
this video explained the threats for
tesla stock
well and of course consider joining our
discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you